when little men uses stats against you
I'm working on a new project I just
launched a new video it's called believe
at six minutes long and it tells an
important story for people to break out
of their comfort zone to try something
new to take risks to believe in
themselves and push for a better life
it's an inspiring video something that
I'm really proud of making and it's
helped a lot of people now little man
got a hold of it and he watched it and
he tells me this is six minutes long
it's never going to work and he comes up
with a stat so this is the status what
he writes he says the average length of
the top 50 videos on YouTube was two
minutes and 54 seconds so according to
him no video is where no video should be
longer than three minutes if you want to
have success on YouTube like I where
does this guy come up with this stuff it
just it boggles my mind how people
actually believe this stuff I don't even
look into that stat but it doesn't
matter because a lot of the videos that
are popular on YouTube are going to be
pet tricks cute kittens babies crawl
around the floor and the other half hour
music videos that's not what I'm trying
to make the stuff i like is more like
the TED Talks if you guys seem TED Talks
some of the greatest speeches most
inspirational most fought changing
speeches are on TED talks and none of
those are three minutes and they've got
millions of views this guy blows my mind
and
the problem here the problem isn't that
mrs. little man's belief the problem is
that for the little man in your life his
belief his doubt can hold you back from
doing something great what if I had gone
to little man before I made the video
and said here's my idea and he told me
kept you longer than three minutes what
have that killed my dream right there
now I've gotten to the point in my
career where I don't care about what
little man has to say his opinions don't
matter to me but I care about you
because you have a little men in your
life and you go to them for feedback and
even if they don't know anything about
what you're doing they have no expertise
no credentials no credibility they're
doubt makes you doubt yourself and that
that enrages me how did that video do
well we've had a hundred thousand people
in three weeks watch the video it's been
translated into 13 languages by people
in the community who just love it and
say I need to make this in a different
language it's had tons of thumbs ups and
comments and shares and feedback and the
most important for me the most
gratifying are the people who write in
to me and say thank you for making this
video it helped me get through today
that means something to me that's why
I'm in this business wide do this oh I
forgot it's not three minutes long so
therefore it's not going to work it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous how little
man can believe these things and more
importantly how sometimes we as
entrepreneurs listen to the little man
instead of believing in ourselves we
trust in them more than we trust in
ourselves so start believing you guys
like this video give it a thumbs up
below let me know you think leave a
comment underneath you have a question
leave a below-market video response and
if you want to see more videos like this
subscribe to the channel by clicking on
my face thank you so much and I'll see
you soon
you